got a great question from a viewer which
says mass is supposed to be logical
right it's supposed to make sense to us
now my question to you is are there any
mathematical concepts that are
counterintuitive concepts that don't
seem logical at all yet somehow work am
I answer that question is to begin with
yes there are some ideas that seem
counterintuitive at the start but after
you think about them eventually the
logic behind them does become clearer if
you know enough maths to see why so
illustrate that let me give you three
examples of concepts that seem
counterintuitive and they're all going
to come from infinite series and
sequences because that's what I'm
teaching at the moment so that's kind of
what's on my mind so the first thing to
explain to you is the harmonic series
the harmonic series now the first thing
to understand about the harmonic series
and why it's unusual is to think about
series like this so for instance if I
said 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 plus 1/16 and
so on forever now this is a series
that's made up of fractions and each
time the fraction is getting smaller
it's having each time as you can see now
even though there's an infinite number
of terms the truth is now all of these
add up to a finite number in other words
it's a convergent series the values
converge on a particular value when you
take up the take the sum now to see what
this particular sum is equal to it's
easy to imagine if you imagine a 1 meter
distance okay and you've got a frog that
can jump half the distance that it sees
in front of it every single time so it's
going to jump half that distance 50
centimeters and then it's gonna jump 25
centimeters and then it's going to jump
12 and 1/2 centimeters and so on 1/2 1/2
1/2 and so on what's gonna happen even
if this frog jumps forever each jump
having the distance that's left till it
gets the end of the one meter it'll
never get there because all of the jumps
it can do will never actually complete
the distance it'll only get you half as
close so this distance a half a meter
plus a quarter of a meter plus an eighth
of a meter and
so on in the end if I could jump in an
infinite number of times with a frog
rather it would be converging on the
number one these even though if a number
of terms together equal finite value
okay so it's a convergent series now the
harmonics use looks very very similar to
this one the harmonic series goes like
this
it's 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/3 plus 1/4 plus
1/5 and so on forever the fancy way of
writing that in Sigma notation will be
the sum of 1 over n from N equals 1 to
infinity
now the weird thing about this is even
though the values as you go along issues
are shrinking just like they were here
if you take them all together they don't
converge on any value they diverge they
never approach anything it's getting
smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller but this number the whole thing
it just keeps on growing forever and it
never shrinks towards something sensible
like this so I think that's kind of
unusual that's counterintuitive but
there's a proof that shows that the
harmonic series is divergent if you know
enough maths to understand it so there's
a counter it should have
counterintuitive idea but it does make
sense ok now let me show you another
series okay it goes like this it's very
similar to the harmonic series
it starts with 1 videos 1 over 1 plus 1
over 1 times 2 plus 1 over 1 times 2
times 3 and 1 over 1 times 2 times 3
times 4 and so on forever ok so a
fancier way of writing that or a more
concise way of writing that would be 1
plus 1 on 1 factorial 1 on 2 factorial
that's what 2 times 1 is 1 on 3
factorial 1 on 4 factorial 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 and so on forever ok if
we wanted to write that all in Sigma
notation and there'd be sum of 1 over N
factorial from N equals 0 to infinity
now the question arises over well is
this gonna be convergent or divergent
the answer is it is converge
but it's converging on a very unusual
number it's converging on the number
2.71828
one eight two eight four five I think
it's a nine next oh four five two three
five three six and on and on forever
this that was so important it gets a
special name namely e it often comes up
in situations to do with exponential
growth or exponential decay and it's
what the the natural log is named after
now here's the unusual thing about this
now but if you look for a pattern from
one number to the next you'll never find
one there is no way to predict just off
one number what the next one will be
okay
in fact it's it's even more unusual than
that it's not just an irrational number
it's what we call a transcendental
number which has to do with solutions to
polynomials and numbers that can't be
formed as solutions to polynomials and
he's another example of a transcendental
numbers pie okay
and he's the weird thing here's what I
think is counterintuitive we started off
we formed this series in a very
structured predictable way you could
predict exactly what the next term will
be with a great deal of certainty okay
but when we put together this very
predictable thing what you end up with
is a completely unpredictable thing you
can never know what the next number will
be just by looking at what this
immediately preceding number is that's
kind of intuitive that you can take
something predictable and produce
something in some ways unpredictable but
it's true and it can also be proved just
like the result with the harmonic series
so there you go another counterintuitive
thing all right the last one I want to
show to you is about different
affinities so this is not a series this
is going to be a sequence that we're
going to look at we're not going to add
things up now what I say different your
videos what does that even mean well you
say well infinity is infinity right well
the thing is infinity is not a number
it's just a concept that it's an idea
and there are different ways to think
about it for instance if I gave you the
set of natural numbers of the counting
numbers that's one two should put a
brace there one two three four
five and so on forever okay if he's the
great thing about this when I look at
this series even though it would take me
forever I could count it because from
one term I can know what the next one is
without counting one two then three then
four then five you know exactly what
comes next which is why you can count so
we call this a countably infinite set if
you wanted to count it you could do it
it would take you forever but you can't
count it because the numbers have this
order to them okay now here's the weird
thing
if I just look at say that numbers
probably wanted to let's just let's just
zoom in there okay one and two now if I
were to count the decimals between one
and two it's common sense says well
there probably will be an infinite
number of them as well and there are but
there are more numbers more decimals
between one and two then there are
numbers in the natural set of numbers
what did you for five up to infinity
what do I mean well let's try and play
the same trick that we were before we're
doing before with the natural numbers
when you go from one double you can tell
me what the next one is by counting 1
then 2 then 2 then 3 and then so on okay
well what would be the numbers we wanted
to well you could say what would be the
next upper along maybe you could say
well 1.1 that's in between isn't it
between wanted to then I could count 1.2
1.3 and so on but I could say no no no
this that's not the next number there's
another number between 1 and 1 point 1
namely well point oh one that's that's
stuck in between there isn't it so maybe
the next number is 1.01 it I think Carol
a pointer to 0.3 and so on the answer is
no it's not because if I'd go in between
again I can stick 1.001 between 1.0 1
and 1 so I can play this game forever
and I will never actually know what the
next number is to count ok so that's
weird I can keep on doing this forever
there are not countably infinite numbers
between wanted to now what we call
uncountably infinite
you could count forever and still not
get to the end so that's weird that
there are in somewhere in a way of
saying it there are more numbers between
one and two that there are from one to
infinity that's bizarre it's
counterintuitive now like I said before
there is a proof for this result as well
but obviously you'll need to know some
pretty funky number theory maths with
discrete numbers to understand
so it's Cappadocia to begin with so it
starts off that way and many things in
maths are but once you dwell on
something and I learn more maths to be
able to manipulate things there you do
see that things are logical in the end